J'ai reçu la visite, il y a presque exactement un an,
un peu plus d'un an, d'un très haut responsable du Ministère de la Défense.
Il est venu me voir et m'a dit : "1600 des gosses que nous avons envoyés
sont revenus avec au moins un bras en moins.
L'ensemble du bras. L'épaule désarticulée.
Et nous faisons plus ou moins la même chose que nous avons fait
depuis la guerre de Sécession, un bâton et un crochet.
Et ils méritent mieux que ça.
Et littéralement, cet homme s'est assis dans mon bureau dans le New Hampshire et a dit :
"Je veux que vous me donniez quelque chose que nous puissions mettre sur ces gosses
qui puisse prendre un raisin sec ou un grain de raisin sur une table,
et qu'ils puissent le mettre dans leur bouche sans détruire ni l'un ni l'autre,
et qu'ils soient en mesure de faire la différence, sans le regarder."
Vous savez, avec une réponse efférente, afférente, et haptique.
Il termine son explication, et je m'attends au gros dossier de projet de 150 kilos.
et il dit : "Voilà ce que j'attends de vous."
J'ai dit : "Ecoutez, vous êtes dingue. Cette technologie n'existe pas actuellement.
Et c'est infaisable.
Pas dans l'enveloppe d'un bras humain,
avec 21 degrés de liberté, de votre épaule jusqu'aux bouts de vos doigts."
Il a dit : "Environ deux douzaines de ces 1600 gosses sont revenus sans leurs deux bras.
Vous pensez que c'est terrible de perdre un bras ?
C'est une simple gène par rapport à perdre les deux à la fois."
J'ai un travail de jour,
et mes nuits et week-ends sont déjà remplis avec des choses du genre,
fournissons de l'eau et de l'énergie au monde, et éduquons tous les enfants,
et, je t'assure Chris, que je ne vais pas en parler ici. Je n'ai pas besoin d'une autre mission.
Je continue de penser à ces gosses sans bras.
Il me dit : "Nous avons fait quelques travaux dans plusieurs coins du pays.
Nous avons des neurologues très étonnants et d'autres spécialistes."
J'ai dit : "Je vais faire un voyage d'étude, je vais aller voir où vous en êtes."
Au cours du mois suivant, j'ai visité beaucoup d'endroits, certains près d'ici, à travers le pays,
trouvé les meilleurs des meilleurs.
Je suis allé à Washington, j'ai vu ces gars-là, et j'ai dit :
"J'ai fait ce que vous m'avez demandé. J'ai examiné ce qui existe.
Je continue de penser que vous êtes dingues. Mais pas aussi dingues que je le pensais."
J'ai mis une équipe sur pied, il y a un peu plus de 13 mois,
j'ai rassemblé une vingtaine de personnes.
Nous avons dit, nous allons construire un appareil conforme à ce qu'on nous demande.
Nous avons 14 des 21 degrés de liberté ;
on n'a pas besoin de ceux qui concernent les deux derniers doigts.
Nous avons assemblé ce truc.
Il y a quelques semaines, nous l'avons emmené à l'hôpital militaire Walter Reed,
qui est malheureusement plus souvent dans l'actualité ces temps-ci.
Nous l'avons montré à un groupe de gars.
Un gars qui se disait chanceux,
car il a perdu son bras gauche, et qu'il est droitier.
Il s'est assis à une table avec sept ou huit de ces autres gars.
Il a dit qu'il avait de la chance, car il a son bon bras,
et puis il s'est repoussé pour s'éloigner de la table. Il n'avait pas de jambes.
Vous n'imaginez pas la force de caractère de ces jeunes.
Alors, je vais vous montrer maintenant, sans peau dessus,
une vidéo de 30 secondes, et je termine.
Mais comprenez-bien : ce que vous voyez
nous l'avons fait assez petit pour équiper un individu de sexe féminin de taille moyenne,
pour que nous puissions le mettre sur n'importe laquelle de ces personnes.
On le mettra dans quelque chose que nous utilisons dans scanners et
les IRMs de leur bon bras que ce soit le droit ou le gauche,
pour fabriquer un caoutchouc de silicone, puis le recouvrir, et le peindre en 3D,
une image qui soit un miroir exact de leur autre membre.
Donc, vous ne verrez pas tous les trucs vraiment chouettes qu'il y a dans cette série élastique de 14 actionneurs,
chacun étant individuellement capable de sentir la température et la pression.
Il y a également un manchon pneumatique qui le maintient en place,
donc plus ils se mettent en charge, plus ça tient.
Ils reposent la charge, et l'appareil se relâche de nouveau.
Je vais vous montrer un gars qui fait une ou deux choses simple avec ça
lors d'une démonstration que nous avons faite à Washington. Est-ce qu'on peut voir ça ?
Regarder les doigts qui saissisent. Le pouce se lève. Le poignet.
Ça pèse 3,10 kilos.
Il va se gratter le nez.
Il a 14 degrés de liberté actifs.
Maintenant, il va prendre un stylo avec le pouce opposé et l'index.
Maintenant, il va le reposer, prendre un morceau de papier,
tourner tous les degrés de liberté dans la main et le poignet, et le lire.
(Applaudissements)